and good morning one and all welcome to
it the crystal Sado show our two already
under way coming up with the bottom a
our Eric Trump making the closing
argument for the Republicans his
father's policies in particular so we'll
hear from him but right on the top gonna
try something a little different I was
approached by the producer of this
gentlemen's show and I found the idea
intriguing sooner or later this
country's going to figure out how to
talk to each other again maybe David
Pakman and I can can get this going he's
the creator and the host of the
nationally syndicated program the David
Pakman show his program airs on free
speech TV 200 TV radio stations around
the country and the shows on YouTube as
well over 350 million views and 500,000
subscribers
mr. Pakman welcome to the crusaders show
so look let me start off on a
complimentary basis here since we're
trying to foster understanding at least
of each other's positions I've got to
applaud you unlike other liberal talk
show hosts you're honest about who you
are and what you do I'm talking about
Jim Acosta he's a liberal talk show host
he can't he can't be honest about who he
is Wolf Blitzer virtually the entire
so-called news staff of MSNBC they're
not honest about who they are but you
are and so I want to applaud you for
that because at least folks understand
where you're coming from now that when
your producer sent me the information
about what you wanted to talk about
he said that in particular you thought
what the president is doing what the
border issues was all a distraction
go ahead explain well it's not a
distraction in the sense that it's a
deliberately planted distraction you
know I think that sometimes we attribute
too much forethought to some of these
things so there's certainly no way in
which the Blazer issue is not an
important issue the idea of removing
birthright citizenship by executive
order which most legal experts say is
just not going to happen by having a
planted distraction to be clear the
timing of it as well as the timing of
you know claims that the migrant caravan
is an invasion I think that it's
important for everybody not to not to
forget that it's time to vote right
tomorrow there's an election and that's
the most immediate thing no matter what
your politics are that you can do
they try to have your voice heard about
what you think the policy should be yeah
and let me give you a perspective from
the right as as somebody who is a
staunch supporter of legal immigration
but I despise and loathe illegal
immigration I think it's immoral I think
it's wrong and I think it's bad for any
nation forced to endure it by its
political class this is an ongoing issue
the president his rhetoric hasn't
changed from the time he came down that
escalator to today to sit there and say
that this is all fabricated or he's
dealing with this this language of his
before an election and is using it to
gin up the conservative base I don't I
think ignores the last two years of the
very same rhetoric don't you yeah I'm
not saying he's using it to gin up the
conservative base I just think it's
important you know in speaking to my
audience which is of course you know
primarily people on the Left although
you look at my email inbox you'll notice
there's a lot of right-wingers as well
my message was he's not going to remove
birthright citizenship by executive
order by Tuesday and thus the most
important thing is make sure you're
registered make sure you know where it
is that that you need to go make sure
you know who the candidates are because
this is an issue that is going to be
dealt with if he actually tries to pass
this by executive order it'll be dealt
with but it's not going to happen
between now and Tuesday so that was my
message don't be distracted in that
particular time let me on birthright
citizenship because I think it's an
important discussion the country needs
to have birthright citizenship by
executive order I agree with you the
president cannot doesn't have the
authority the same way that Barack Obama
didn't have the authority to do half of
his executive orders or whenever he
bothered to do executive orders most of
time it was just a memo when he let he
just told people to do it and they did
it in his administration I don't believe
the president has the authority and I
don't even think that was the goal I
think ultimately but this the goal is to
finally have this question adjudicated
to the Supreme Court level do you
disagree I don't know what you're
attributing much more calculation and
strategy to Donald Trump then I have
evidence to suggest he's capable of so I
think what you're saying is possible but
I don't I don't that's not my position
right now because I've not seen evidence
of that
isn't that a an Achilles heel though of
the left I mean isn't your side
constantly under estimating this guy as
being some sort of dunce or doofus much
the way they they did Ronald Reagan no I
don't think so I think he's proven
himself to be a Dunton doofus but he
does have people around him who you know
people like Steve Bannon and Steve
Miller and others who are not doofuses
and as a result of that he has been able
to be attached to actual things that
have been done but no I think that the
idea that he's a dunce in doofus is
pretty well back okay david pakman our
guest right now folks as you could hear
he does what I do but on the other side
ladies and gentleman he's a liberal talk
show host for the David Pakman show
nationally syndicated let's let's pivot
now to one of what what your side views
is a strong issue which is which is
health care and and the Obama care
takeover of health insurance Kent can
you hang your hat on the successes of
Obama care
yeah well listen I I thought Obama care
was not the right approach to begin with
I'm actually on the left so for me when
you say here's an idea
let's mandate that we give millions and
millions of new customers to the
for-profit insurance companies that are
a huge part of the problem that's not
the plan I would put together right
Chris so I think we can identify
failings and we can identify sort of
successes right I mean I think what what
we do know is that the rate at which
premiums have increased in the exchange
health insurance plans has been a lower
rate of increase than in the broader
health insurance market so is that like
a massive victory if we're thinking
about where we want to be in 20 years
no is it slightly better than the
direction things were going yes here
well where I am in Massachusetts we've
had something that is very similar to
Obamacare for many more years and we
have the highest rate of insured in the
country we have one of the highest
standards of care in the country and I
think that it's it's always sort of like
well compared to what and compared to
doing nothing at all I think it's better
is this the ideal thing I would propose
no it's not yeah and according
USA Today you guys may have more insured
but your your wait times have exploded
as well because of Romney care which of
course I objected to and I think you and
I might have just found some common
ground I call them the traitorous
insurance companies because they because
they conspired with the Obama
administration to screw the American
people which is exactly what they did
to flow nothing new about that I mean in
other words there's nothing unique about
the conspiracy with any particular
administration this is something that
goes back decades
since the United States decided in the
period between World War 1 and World War
2 not to go the direction of European
health care system so I agree but it
didn't start in 2008 it actually started
you know closer to 100 years ago right
and the the Department of our the Health
and Human Services Department published
studies which which showed that premiums
even outside of the exchanges on average
across the board have risen $3,000 from
2013 to 2017 which of course is a stark
contrast to mr. Obama's promise of
saving $2,500 for an average family of
four you and I can both agree that more
expensive isn't saving correct more
expensive isn't saving but you're sort
of playing fast and loose with the
numbers because it's very easy to just
say hey premiums went up and therefore
everything that was said was a lie and
to be clear Chris I am with you in
criticizing the way that the system has
continued to break down over the last
five years however many years you want
to say but if we're gonna do a serious
statistical analysis and I don't know if
we even have the time for that you can't
just say if prices go up everything was
a lie you have to account for inflation
you have to compare programs within
Obamacare to those outside of it and as
I said premiums went up more slowly for
the plans within Obamacare so yes I
don't want prices going up but we've got
to consider a lot of other important
economic factors if we want to take this
serious sure and I you know when I know
that my out-of-pocket costs and not not
just the premiums the deductibles are
going up crazy because of all these
fandangled rules under this nonsensical
law that was tens of thousands of pages
long that nobody read before they passed
the dang
look maybe you and I have a bit of
agreement here but let me ask you and
we're not going to be able to drill down
the numbers maybe on future shows we
will if our relationship continues here
but let me ask you about why your
approach to health care should be
trusted because we all know that it was
Ted Kennedy who gave us the the now
failed HMO system we now know it was
Barack Obama who gave us this whatever
you can call Obamacare I don't think
it's achieved any of the promises that
it that it that it made and then now
your side is saying well trust us again
this time we're going to get it right
and we're gonna go with a complete
government takeover of health care why
should we continue to trust your side
with arguably one of the most important
life decisions an individual can make
well Chris I mean you're framing the
question in a completely unfair way so
just to give you a couple of examples
how you're doing that is number one when
you talk about my side and why should I
be why should my views trusted when Ted
Kennedy did access Barack Obama is why
right I've never been a Democrat in my
life I was critical of the fact that the
Obama care proposal was a far too
conservative proposal so the idea that
because Obamacare isn't what you want a
completely different approach that I
might have is by default to be
distressed that is logically fallacious
and I know look wait a minute hold on
hold on I understand the desire to
separate yourself from Democrat brand I
haven't been a Republican in years I'm a
conservative I'm so far above the the
Republican brand and from my ideological
perspective it's not even funny I'm sure
you as a mahfaeraak Alling you a liberal
I don't know I mean I think that a
program that mandates that even when
people get into profit insurance it's
bad so that I would see something like a
medicare-for-all proposal okay so
single-payer so but again there are a
lot of folks on the Democrat side that
share your point of view and again the
Democrats don't have a great track
record with health care everything that
they have imposed in this country has
failed so again why should we trust the
the largely held popular view among the
Democrat Party of
single-payer medicare-for-all whatever
you want to call it why should we
embrace that when everything else that
they have instituted is failed yeah we
don't need to look at the track record
of Republicans or Democrats on this
issue because they've both been co-opted
by the for-profit insurance companies
and the lobbying industrial complex
status quo so I think we just need to
look at look at countries that have
implemented this successfully you don't
need to evaluate whether Ted Kennedy
said X or Mitch McConnell wants Y or
anything like that it's the system we
have has failed because of Democrats and
Republicans and we should look at the
programs that are instituted in places
where it succeeded all right folks this
of course we have a lot more to discuss
I'm sure and David Pakman I look for up
nice to meet you first off and and and
plaid thank you for being here
nationally syndicated program folks the
David Pakman show and you can just look
it up on Google and because I did and
you will find all of the various ways to
listen to his program sir appreciate the
time and the discussion thank you for
having me
you betcha to a 1 5 8 5 7 3 8 to a 1 5 i
vacay SUV interesting perspective so
we've heard from the left see there was
no shouting there was no name-calling it
was a it was a discussion of policies
how how interesting it can be
accomplished my friends back in a minute
the christelle sato show Eric trump the
bottom of the hour don't miss it on the
voice of Texas